you know joe rogan now i understand he
has 200 million uh listeners yeah and
there are people who go i want to go
after him for it and howard stern is one
of them and howard stern probably has a
similar audience to joe rogan maybe and
i just want to read you what howard
stern said to him quote we have no time
for idiots in this country anymore
we don't want you
we want you uh to all either go to the
hospital and stay home die there with
your kovid don't take the cure but don't
clog up our hospitals with your covid
when you finally get it remember when
howard stern said that podcasts were
never gonna take off
because he was the first and everything
no he's doing radio and so he's like a
podcast was stupid who's ever going to
watch that he's doing even satellite
radio yes but i'm saying like he never
liked podcasting or podcasting you
thought it was stupid but he was pretty
much and i was way bigger than him but
he was pretty much the first podcast you
shooting on podcast is basically
[ __ ] on your kids that is a very
very harsh statement from howard stern
directed at joe rogan but then i don't
think by saying you're an idiot it's
going to change a person's mind that's
why i love science i didn't even change
his mind
you're not going to change your mind
you're not trying to change joe's mind
but out of 200 million people that are
listening there might be a mind change
and i i sanjay respect
he respected joe enough to actually go
on there
not less we right now run to our own
echo chambers and we we would rather
have applause from preaching to our own
choirs than actually moving the needle
at all i think this was so important to
go on there not to convince joe rogan
and not have the intention of convincing
anyone else provide the facts answer
with science let people make up their
own minds that's the problem in this day
and age we're telling people how to feel
they will feel what they want give them
enough information that they make that
decision and win on merit dr gupta did
something very interesting when he got
there he pointed out that rogan sells
masks on his site even though he wasn't
a big mask he and he gave it to him as a
gift during the interview and then he
also brought up to him during the
interview when i got here there was a
rapid test done to me and then they also
uh pricked my finger for the presence of
antibodies he's a hypocrite on top of
his heart
how is he a hypocrite
he said it's fine to use tests he
actually has been very transparent about
the fact that he gets tests every time
he brings in a guest so this idea that
he's a hypocrite he's like listen it's
not because people are anti-vaccine that
they're anti-all measures it's not
because people are anti-mandate that
they're not for the vaccine
me for example i'm pro-vaccine
anti-mandates that's me personally
people can be nuanced so using a
hypocrite in this is very funny to me
because it's clear that you must live in
some kind of binary where you can't
imagine that joe was like i don't want
the vaccine but i still get tested it's
not because you don't get the vaccine
that you don't believe in something
that's real you can believe in the
illness that's the thing
that's the thing we're so polarized
we're so black and white
blue and red
that's not what it is
that's not reality that's how anything
functions shout out to the two ladies
before them because they were making a
lot of sense you don't want to convince
somebody come bring bring your set of
facts and your ideas have the debate
back and forth and let the people decide
for themselves that's it
she was preaching
but i mean
showed up and said by the way to all you
listeners i just am providing facts he
didn't bring emotion
uh i think soundy is a very effective
spokesperson because he's not as
politicized and demonized right as some
of the cdc nih doctors have been was
until he went on don lemon got his back
broken
he did he bent over and he took it right
so i think he and he's listen sanjay
gupta is not just a tv doctor sanjay
gupta is a real doctor at every
university doing neurosurgery but the
other thing about joe rogan if you look
at his yes he has all of these listeners
that's so wonderful but some of the
stuff that he has said he's transphobic
he's islamophobic he has said racist
things i mean another one with the
trifecta of bigotry and and and these
are these people continue to listen to
him don't bring past [ __ ] to this even
whatever the hell you said was kind of
enronist but it's okay someone that says
something
unbelievably wrong doesn't mean that
they say everything again with the
[ __ ] left and right and black and
blue and red and blue and black
it's not because you said something that
is that you don't agree with that
everything you say is going to be
something that is
horrendously wrong you just dropped it
though she just dropped it he's
transphobic homophobic he's a terrible
person why where's
you know why they called joe trans folk
go ahead because he said it wasn't right
for females to be facing males in mma
fights that in athletics there's a clear
advantages transphobe really you're
gonna say that do you know that vast
majority of people think that that's not
right for males and females to be
competing in the same sport
that makes everybody a transphobe they
refer to joe rogan's audience of so many
millions of people as all idiots and
then afterwards they wonder why people
are not following their rules you
alienate people
you call them dumbasses stupid not
recognizing there's a variety of people
who watch joe rogan for different
reasons i personally like watching it
for some of the guests sometimes he has
a guest that really interests me who
brings in really interesting information
on sleep studies on the history of the
world there's interesting [ __ ] sometimes
and also you have time today and he's
and he's knowledgeable about mma on a
podcast like joe rogan these people have
time to develop whenever you go on these
shows like the view that what we're the
second that we're watching right now you
watch whatever they invite someone to
talk about these things like they're
gonna talk they're gonna invite a
neurosurgeon that neurosurgeon is only
gonna have like about seven minutes to
expose all of that i'm not going to get
all the information i want but if i
watch jorgen it's going to be two
hours or two hours and a half of back
and forth about that subject he has
advised young people if you're young and
you're healthy don't take the vaccine i
think if you are still listening to him
knowing his history i'm not interested
in in in reaching out to you i would
like to ask you something
and they might be you know you want you
might want to call them crazy you might
want to call them stupid you might want
to call them idiots here's the problem
that idiot might be your shoe salesman
that idiot might be your cashier at the
public and what about it we you're going
to you know we want to do that you're
getting their money to that person what
do you
sorry says you don't what would you like
him to say in five seconds what would i
like sanjay what would you like him to
say you say don't call people idiots
because i don't want anybody calling me
an idiot for what i believe in yeah you
were going to change my mind when you
have a respectful discourse because i
want to make my own decisions there are
people that still listen to joe that
still are they're wavering yeah there
was an interesting point during the
pandemic i think like last
this past summer that just passed and
you know most
i've gotten people at that point people
like why would you wait so long i was
like breath maybe i was unsure it's not
your business but not everyone's certain
not everyone's for or against it people
are still getting vaccinated so just
stop pigeonholing everyone all these
people get up on these platforms you're
a [ __ ] idiot that's killing your
neighbors okay cool you know at the
beginning of the pandemic on the onset
of it a lot of you dumbasses got mad at
folks for banning travel from china a
lot of you folks got mad at other people
for saying that this may have came from
a lab and come to find out later on you
were the idiots because you were
ill-informed if formation is constantly
evolving stop looking at the other side
of the aisle with this like righteous
indignation like you're inherently right
you don't know you don't know
you don't know and a lot of other people
don't know and they're taking their time
to make their decisions
just stop this is a whole conversation
man shout out to her because she was
very civil with it and she i think made
a good point where it's like both of
them i know people who are hyper
religious
i'm not it's never going to be for me i
don't go out there like you [ __ ]
idiot for believing in sky daddy or
whatever it is it's like man
no it's stupid right
what
you're gonna start probably first first
space friend
yeah mouse guy daddy bruv whatever oh
kai daddy all this is saying
all this to sing there's kai daddy
oh i'm sorry that's a great name all
right all right all right so
all this to say i'm sorry what
kind idea is a great name yeah yeah when
you alienate people like this you don't
give them any incentive to want to meet
you halfway you don't want to that's
fine afterwards though i don't want to
hear none of y'all
complaining about why people aren't
following rules and regulations or why
people are not coming to the table to
have a conversation you already call
them stupid and retards undertapped
they're not coming to the table all
right
you want to look at the polarization and
the media landscape understand the ways
in which you contribute by referring to
anybody who does this as stupid or
anything
it's not good conversation anyways
that's it
sky daddy